bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 9 juillet
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau
numéro de fini co votre magazine
d'actualité qui revient sur l'économie
locale avec cette semaine un numéro un
peu spéciale en numéro était car c'est
là notre dernière émission de la saison
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
le cv vidéo c'est un outil utile dans la
recherche d'emploi son utilisation se
développe et il plaît aux recruteurs
nous y reviendrons à suivre liesse
initiative 100% yvelinoise le principe
un job d'été pour les étudiants et un
service pour les personnes âgées du
département il sample ans par le conseil
départemental depuis plus de dix ans
enfin pour cette émission estivale pour
ça qu'on notre dossier de la semaine au
parc de loisirs et du mois pour en
baigner france miniature où l'espace
rambouillet trois sites parmi les plus
attractives du département nous verrons
comment ils s'organisent pour les
périodes cruciales pour leur économie
et enfin cette semaine un autre
entretien nous reviendrons sur promo
paul la pépinière d'entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines
othman à ce rouleau président de promo
paul viendra nous en parler nous
reviendrons dans quelques instants sur
cette année passée qui a été compliqué
donc pour la pépinière d'entreprises
mais avant cela place au reportage
et nous ouvrons cette édition avec un
mot sur l'emploi et le recrutement au
moment de postuler il est parfois
difficile de se distinguer avec un
simple cv ils sont souvent tous
construits autour du même modèle et les
bons candidats ne manquent pas il existe
une alternative qui se développe c'est
le cv vidéo à saint quentin en yvelines
une entreprise vous propose ce service
anna jimenez éolienne elle n'aura vidéo
action n'aura n'est pas une habitude de
la caméra si aujourd'hui elle se prête
au jeu
c'est pour créer son cv vidéo une
solution pour sortir du lot selon une
enquête ipsos france 53 % des candidats
sont prêts à l'utiliser
titulaire d'un bts commercial elle
trouve cette idée innovante pour moi
c'est un gain temps c'est à dire que
l'employeur va directement voir le
profil que tu as s'il a intéressé te
contacte s'il n'est pas intéressé en
fait ça sert à rien de deux de se
déplacer de perdre du temps à faire des
entretiens axés un gain de temps pour
tous le cv vidéo permet aux recruteurs
de trouver la perle rare
55 % utilisent cette nouvelle technique
pour sélectionner leur candidat pour
être efficace la vidéo ne doit pas
dépasser les 2 minutes francisco
s'arrêtera à monter son entreprise cisco
vidéo depuis quelques mois
installé à promo paul il a réalisé une
dizaine de cv vidéo et les retours sont
positifs ya ce côté aussi humains qui
font vraiment mettre en avant puisque un
candidat n'est pas qu'un bout de papier
mais il ya quelqu'un aussi qui pourra
s'intégrer dans une équipe dans une
entreprise qui pourra apporter vraiment
un savoir faire non seulement à savoir
faire mais aussi ses expériences et
aussi sa personnalité
avant de réaliser son cd vidéo un
coaching est primordial pour transmettre
le meilleur de soi bien synthétiser ses
qualités et ses compétences avec
originalité
il m'a conseillé sur les postures sur
comment tourner un petit peu les phrases
et puis
finalement ça s'est fait une fois le
tournage terminé le cv vidéo accompagne
le sait les classiques sous forme de
codes barres pratique pour regarder sur
l'ordinateur ou le téléphone portable
le but ultime c'est que vraiment obtenir
un rendez-vous en rendez-vous
d'entretien et aussi que lorsque le
candidat va se présenter face à horrues
kritter ce recruteur il est déjà
l'impression de le connaître puisqu'il
aura déjà vu sur son cv vidéo coût du
service 89 euros pour un demandeur
d'emploi 39 euros pour les étudiants au
premier emploi un investissement qui
peut s'avérer rentable selon
l'association mozaïk rh un candidat à
trois fois plus de chances de décrocher
un entretien d'embauché avec un cv vidéo
et pour nora l'expérience a été positive
car elle a décroché un entretien et même
un travail elle devrait commencer au
moins de septembre
parlons maintenant emplois saisonniers
l'été de nombreux étudiants cherchent un
job pour financer leurs études ou se
faire de l'argent de poche
le conseil départemental propose pour la
onzième année de suite son dispositif
yes
ils viennent étudiants seniors un emploi
saisonnier
placée sous le signe de l'entr'aide
intérieur intergénérationnel pardon
regardez ces images d'elodie one comme
chaque semaine depuis le mois de juillet
laura va rendre visite à huguette 87 ans
elles se sont rencontrées grâce au
dispositif vieillesse yvelines étudiants
seniors un job d'été pour les jeunes
désireux de s'impliquer auprès des
anciens et pour les personnes âgées une
heure de combat ni par semaine j'essaie
était passée continue
c'est agréable sachant ça permet de voir
d'autres personnes d'autres horizons ou
dix ans
là on a rien à débourser alors quand on
va à manille faire un auto il arrive
quand des jeunes peuvent ont fait un
plat chaque cas puis encore tâche tout
un échange de bons procédés
les étudiants ont un contrat de 35
heures et touchent le smic il vaut entre
15 et 20 personnes âgées par semaine
mais comme pour laura c'est souvent plus
qu'un jeu des t il
les messins pliké on n'est pas du tout
comme des aides ménagères par exemple
c'est vraiment la dissociation on est là
pour apporter du bon temps pour discuter
donc on peut discuter après si la
personne a besoin de faire une émission
spéciale par exemple au cimetière où
aller chez le coiffeur mais c'est
vraiment des tâches ponctuelles c'est
pas les courses le ménage et après on
peut aussi je peux l'emmener faire
défaut on peut aussi se promener faingaa
vraiment je m'adapte vraiment à la
personne ce qu'elle veut faire
des fois on a qui sont habitués juste
pour discuter parce qu'elles n'ont pas
de personnes forcément qu'ils adorent
faire pour tenir compagnie un service
financé par le conseil départemental
pour quatre cent mille euros une somme
qui permet de payer les 150 jeunes
recrutés chaque année pour deux mois
mais le dispositif pourrait évoluer on
est en train de mettre sur pied un
dispositif expérimental avec des jeunes
en service civique dans une région du
mantois dans un autour de
bonnières-sur-seine gargenville nantes
la ville
une expérimentation toute l'année avec
des jeunes en service civique
donc on espère que ça va être concluants
et qu'on pourra étendre ce dispositif à
l'ensemble du département
ils viennent seigneur étudiants existe
déjà depuis dix ans cent mille visites
déjà été rendu aux personnes âgées et
parlons maintenant de promo paul avec
notre entretien de la semaine assez tôt
de suite
et dans notre entretien cette semaine
nous sommes avec eux othman mastrou
bonsoir à vous êtes noir vous êtes le
directeur de promo paul la pépinière
d'entreprises nous avons invité pour ce
dernier et l'émotion pour revenir
justement sur le bilan faire un bilan de
contrôler cette année alors en octobre
2014 la pépinière d'entreprises avaient
été annoncées en cessation de paiement
que s'est il passé depuis parce qu'il ya
eu plusieurs étapes reviendrons dessus
oui il ya beaucoup de choses tout
d'abord vite pourrait qualifier
président du conseil d'administration de
promo paul précisément parce qu'il n'ya
pas de directeur parce que à ma prise de
fonction au lendemain des élections
municipales de 2014
avec le basculement de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines on m'a
confié cette mission est donc gg mis en
suspens la fonction de directeur général
pour que la confiance puisse revenir et
j'ai moi même en tant que président élu
de l'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines voulu prendre les rênes la fin
que la confiance soit rétabli parce que
c'était une structure comme nous
l'avions indiqué à l'époque dans une
situation financière très dégradée avec
un soupçon aussi sur la gestion passée
sur un tas d'actes de gestion qui est
effectivement entachée d'irrégularités
et donc nous avons voulu tout remettre à
plat lors c'est dans ma fonction
effectivement en tant qu'élu qu'on a
souhaité refaire les choses ça a été
tout un feuilleton vous en avais parlé
ici à plusieurs reprises et puis la
presse locale aussi s'est fait l'écho
des différentes péripéties de cette
histoire l'essentiel aujourd'hui pour
tout vous dire c'est qu'on arrive à une
situation je suis en mesure d'annoncer
que promo paul sort des difficultés sur
le plan financier et que la pérennité de
la structure aujourd'hui n'est plus en
danger voilà alors j'aimerais revenir va
sur les différentes étapes donc après la
cessation de paiement il ya aussi des
procédures judiciaires qui ont été
engagées j'aimerais qu'on revienne du
luxueux et pour qu'on m'explique voilà
exactement ce qui s'est passé alors la
première procédure judiciaire ça a été
ma décision d'ouvrir une procédure de
conciliation devant le tribunal de
commerce de versailles que vous avez
indiqué à l'époque et devant les 120
entreprises de la pépinière qu'il
fallait absolument d'abord penser aux
entreprises précisément aux salariés de
la structure et qu'il fallait à en
assurer la pérennité en assainissant
notamment la situation financière et
juridique de cette société donc j'ai
ouvert cette procédure de conciliation
conciliateur a été nommé qui a eu pour
responsabilité de mettre tout le monde
autour de la table de suivre l'évolution
aussi la stratégie de redressement que
j'ai proposé de faire en sorte qu'elle
soit partagée par toutes les parties
prenantes c'est ce qui a été fait cette
conciliation
abouti au mois d'avril ce qui a été
limitée dans le temps un accord entre
toutes les parties prenantes accord aux
termes duquel la pérennité de te promets
pas les garanties alors ça passe par
plusieurs dispositions
la comité d'agglomération notamment à
bandol la créance qu'elle avait puisque
la covedette de mes rations d injecter
500 35000 euros en 2012
la provoc était déjà au bord des
difficultés voilà et deux ans plus tard
il ne restait plus rien que cet argent
dont comme les unes cette alternance où
j'ai pris mes fonctions dont il a
souhaité trouver effectivement on montre
aussi que la structure
reprenez une dynamique positive que
cette créance soit évidemment oublier
l'autre décision ça a été le choix du
maire de trappes de récupérer en gestion
directe la pépinière des merisiers celle
le village d'entreprises de thorez qui
était une délégation de service public
pour cela c'est le maire de trappes
maintenant qui en assurera la gestion 10
n'était pas votre demande
voilà on sépare d'un côté promo pas le
montigny le bretonneux et promos paul
trappe
non ce qui était important pour moi
c'est que quelle que soit la décision
qu'ils soient prises elles le soir
vraiment en étant soucieux de l'argent
public un euro dépensé soit un euro
utile et que bien sûr cette société est
un équilibre financier cohérent là
dessus donc moi j'ai fait ma part du
travail qui consistait essentiellement à
faire en sorte que la gestion soit
optimisé on a fait cent cinquante mille
euros d'économies ce à peu près 20% des
charges qui ont des c entre avait écouté
c'est un travail de bon sens de mise en
concurrence des fournisseurs
d'assainissement de la situation
juridique on se débarrasse du superflu
hurle optimise la gestion des ressources
humaines en évitant d'avoir recours
effectivement voilà des prestataires qui
ne sont pas mis en concurrence
on sent les choses dans les règles de
l'art à chaque étape c'est une gestion
de deux chefs d'entreprise de bon père
de famille et ça a porté ses fruits
puisque c'est essentiellement 5 a permis
d'assurer la pérennité de la société
en parallèle c'est le maire de trappes
qui avait annoncé d'ailleurs que pour
paul serait liquidée et qu'il reprenait
en gestion directe la pépinière de
trappes moins en ce qui me concerne si
c'est sa décision et dans la capacité
juridique mais il fallait bien sûr que
provoque pas le soit indemnisé nous
avons donc que j'ai donc demandé à
certains montants des déterminants
financier soit respectée la ville de
trappes s'est engagé donc dans ce cadre
la hauteur de 2 millions d'euros à peu
près donc
le continuer pour ma part je n'ai pas
encore présidente promole de remarque
supplémentaire à faire sur cela la
question qui reste entière c'est celle
de la gestion passée donc des millions
d'euros je voudrais revenir dessus
ça va être une scène qui va être allouée
à promo paul de vence et les partenaires
plus précisément il ya la grande partie
de la somme c'est une reprise de la
dette
il ya un million six à peu près de dette
qui était un dossier à ce bâtiment qui
passe tu deviens de la dette de la ville
de trappes et non plus à des propos pour
qu'ils se désendette hauteur de 90%
et puis il ya effectivement une
indemnité complémentaire de 400000 euros
qui est qui sera effectivement versée
par la ville de trappes en réparation de
ce qui a été dépensé par probable dans
ce projet du bâtiment des merisiers je
précise encore une fois que ce qui me
concerne l'essentiel c'est que la
société y trouve son compte
mais je n'étais pas effectivement
demandeurs de cette solution lors
pourquoi pas c'était un des scénarios en
tout cas à propos d'aujourd'hui peut
reprendre son chemin vers des horizons
un petit peu plus positif faudrait
revenir sur l'audi qui avaient été
menées dont quatre en vol plané donc
commandé il n'a pas été rendu public
pourtant vous parliez justement de
photographes plus précisément des
anomalies significatives au niveau de la
gestion des ressources humaines
pourquoi ce cet audit n'est-il pas
rendues publiques notamment pour les
entreprises elles sont acropole sais pas
ce que vous voulez dire on dit qu'il est
pas été rendue publique j'ai largement
communiqué sur tout cela on a même fait
le reproche
moi j'ai considéré à l'époque je
continue de le penser qu'il n'ya jamais
d'excès de transparence j'ai même engagé
une procédure c'est sur la place
publique contre mon prédécesseur qui
élus de la ville de trappes qui était
effectivement
précédent président de propofol donc si
tu procédure aussi inquiets public
qu'elle est devant dans les tribunaux et
à chaque fois j'ai donné les éléments
précis là-dessus on a même fait le
reproche donc je crois que tout est sur
la place publique là dessus moi j'ai
aucun problème à rentrer dans le détail
il ya tout un tas de vêtements date de
gestion qui ne sont pas anormaux on
s'interroge sur les rôles des uns et des
autres maintenant il s'agit pas non plus
de faire des accusations à tout va il ya
une présomption d'innocence
naturellement des uns et des autres mais
dans ma responsabilité je vous le redis
aujourd'hui j'irai au bout
j'irai au bout il pas question de lâcher
quoi que ce soit va falloir que chacun
s'explique il ne saurait y avoir
d'impunité le dossier promo pas là était
un naufrage absolue en termes de
mauvaise gestion il va falloir que
chacun rende des comptes donc j'irai au
bout sur chacun des dossiers mais on a
un certain nombre qui soit sur la place
publique et puis sur le reste on
engagera des procédures là où
effectivement les experts des avocats
nous dirons que on est bien fondé à le
faire maintenant l'audit en tant que tel
je crois que tous les éléments sont sur
la table manger diffuser encore auprès
de toutes les entreprises le bilan de
cette année d'action la situation telle
qu on la trouvait dégradé réellement sur
le plan financier
tout ce qu'on a mis en place et puis
vers quoi on va savoir maintenant les
pépinières qui est à la hauteur des
ambitions économiques du territoire
bien sûr les affaires judiciaires sont
encore en cours rien n'est fini
clairement trop en parler mais
j'aimerais qu'on revienne dessus la
responsabilité du coup est allouée à qui
c'est quoi ton quand on prend en charge
une structure et qu'on découvre que dans
cette structure là il y a deux millions
et demi de dette
il ya un chiffre d'affaires qui est en
chute libre avec effectivement des des
locaux qui sont beaucoup vides et qu'il
y a à côté des prestataires ou des des
clients qui sont visiblement privilégié
par rapport à d'autres quand on voit que
malgré les difficultés qui existent
depuis 2009 elle précisé promo pas
l'inconnu en eau six années de pertes
il n'y a pas eu de réduction des délais
de chars le contraire les salaires le
salaire est compris le directeur je
faisais la précision au début
tu es vraiment excessif au regard en
contre le directeur et le président
croit encore oui tout à fait tout à fait
tout à fait alors je vous le dit
précisément ça concerne des factures
dont la réalité m'a paru suspecte et pas
seulement un mois mais aussi
effectivement l'audit indépendant vous
avez cité qu'il ya un vide qui a été
menée par une filiale de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations cet audit a
effectivement s'est interrogé sur des
prestations qui lie à la société du
directeur avec chrome os paul donc là on
est dans le mélange les genres dans le
conflit d'intérêt le plus total et on
pouvait le passé sous silence mais bien
sûr après on ne peut pas tout à fait
tout à fait ça mettra du temps il ya
d'autres volets qui sont en cours
d'étude et ça mettra des années bien sûr
et j'espère ça ne nuira pas à l'image de
marque pépinière mais il n'est pas
question que l'on fasse comme si de rien
n'était justin en revenant sur voilà
l'image de marque de la dernière
maintenant c'est une nouvelle ère entre
guillemets tissons comment cela va se
passer est ce que vous allez en plus et
des nouvelles choses pour tout d'abord
le travail n'est pas fini
là on a un on a battu effectivement un
certain nombre une quantité importante
de travail dans l'assainissement de la
situation c'était le plus urgent le plus
important maintenant il faut qu'on se
tourne vers l'avenir et là dessus il ya
plusieurs choses premièrement il va
falloir vous avez parlé d'image de
marque 37 pépinière davantage attractive
et qu'elle apporte une vraie valeur
ajoutée aux entreprises
donc on est dessus c'est un travail de
réforme en réalité qu'il faut faire la
rendre plus réactive
- administrative d'événements alors oui
il ya un sujet aussi sur l'animation je
crois pas que ce soit l'essentiel je
pense que les entreprises attendent et
les petites entreprises les jeunes
entreprises qu'elles veulent absolument
savoir un environnement qui soit
favorable au développement de leurs
activités ont des loyers pas très cher
avec une souplesse administrative la
réactivité en face et puis bien sûr un
réseau de partenaires mais pépinière n'a
pas vocation à tout faire elle même est
d'ailleurs dans un environnement
privilégié de ce point de vue là savoir
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
qui est dynamique sur lequel il ya des
structures qui vont le travail
remarquable c'est le cas de la maison de
l'entreprise par exemple donc toutes ces
structures là existe mais il faut que
maintenant tout fonctionne de concert
est l'un des projets c'est effectivement
une initiative qui porté par
l'agglomération aujourd'hui qui est
d'avoir un incubateur en complément de
l'offre effectivement de la pépinière
promo paul innovants en termes
d'innovation
autour du quartier de saint quentin en
yvelines près de la gare de
saint-quentin est donc là dessus ça fait
partie des choses sur lesquelles on
travaille parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
voir les choses dans leur ensemble
il n'y a pas traités promo paul d'une
part et le reste de l'autre c'est un
tout c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le
territoire donc là je revienne à
casquette de jeunes élus de
l'agglomération et puis voilà l'objectif
c'est vraiment de faire en sorte que
tout fonctionne de concert et je crois
que ça va nous occuper encore un petit
peu voilà j'espère revenir dans un an
vous dire qu'on a des réalisations très
concrète et très tangible là dessus eh
bien merci entretien de madre nasco
d'avoir répondu à tentation est revenu
sur le bilan de promo paul cette affaire
tient duré un an et certains noms qui
n'est pas fini nous suivrons voilà les
suite justement de la sphère de la
pépinière d'entreprises les mains
content de passer à notre chiffre de la
semaine
90% des professionnels du département
interrogés par le comité régional du
tourisme qualifie de bonne l'activité du
mois juin c'est notre chiffre de la
semaine par rapport à l'année 2000 14 57
% des professionnels du tourisme
estiment que leur activité est en hausse
par rapport au mois précédent donc mai
la clientèle française est en hausse de
même que la clientèle internationale
je vous propose maintenant de passer à
notre partie magazine avec le dossier de
la semaine et les vacances sont là pour
les professionnels du tourisme c'est
synonyme de haute saison
la période la plus importante de l'année
débute pour eux dès le mois de juin
cette semaine nous consacrons un dossier
au parc de loisirs animalier naturel ou
pédagogiques des yvelines nous sommes
allés voir comment ils fonctionnent et
et comment ils se préparer pour la
saison estivale
regardez ce reportage monté avec roman
russe fini
l'été est enfin là pour les parcs de
loisirs comme le zoo de thoiry l'espace
rambouillet ou france miniature
ce n'est pas le début des vacances mais
au contraire la période la plus chargée
de l'année et sinon ces deux loutres
d'asie où c'est le plus petit look qui
existent par rapport aux 13 sous-espèce
alors elles font entre 70 et 80 cm pour
un poids de 4 à 5 kg à peu près plus de
mille animaux sur un domaine de 150
hectares de quoi attirer près de 450
mille visiteurs par an le parc animalier
de thoiry et le troisième site le plus
visité d'île de france hors paris et le
parc de loisirs le plus attractif des
yvelines l'affluence estivale de monde
de l'organisation les 57 employés sont
rejoints par près de trente saisonniers
comme fiona elle est ici pour deux mois
très polyvalent
parce que généralement on peut être au
péage le matin pour l'accueil des
clients en revenir après la boutique des
fois il faut aller dans restauration et
après on vient sur les différents points
de vente du personnel venu prêter main
forte pour accueillir le public dans le
parc france miniature près de 35
contrats saisonniers sont signés le
nombre d'employés passe ainsi
progressivement de 12 à 50 entre le mois
de mai le mois d'août le côté jardinage
désherbage aux arrosages qu'ils
reviendraient les peluches nettoyer les
cours d'eau voilà beaucoup d'entretien
beaucoup de nettoyage
l'emploi généré par les parcs de loisirs
est un enjeu majeur pour les
collectivités en poste permanent
entraîne entre un et trois recrutements
saisonniers une logique due à l'activité
dite de loisirs et touristique
on est sur un fonctionnement très
saisonnier ici c'est à dire que
clairement la haute saison pour nous
c'est 2 avril jusqu'à fin octobre et en
particulier par exemple mais juin c'est
vraiment le pic on a des journées
jusqu'à 1000 1500 voire 2000 visiteurs
cent mille curieux se pressent chaque
année au parc forestier animalier de
rambouillet pour observer les animaux en
liberté et les aigles et rapaces des
visites plus étalée dans le temps qu zoo
de thoiry
chaque week-end entre mai et septembre
près de 3000 personnes s'y rendent
on a besoin de plus d'accueil plus de
caisse plus de renforts au restaurant et
dans les points de vente
donc ça au niveau du personnel c'est un
fait après on a des tâches différentes
même pour ceux qui ne sont pas
saisonnier entre libye
la restauration et la vente de produits
dérivés un week-end à thouaré équivaut à
près de cent mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires en deux jours pour le parc
la haute saison représente en moyenne
60% du chiffre d'affaires global à
l'année des parcs de loisirs avec ses 5
hectares et ses 117 monument historique
à l'échelle 1 30e
le parc france miniature d'elancourt à
vocation pédagogique ne peut maîtriser
tous les paramètres d'une saison réussie
le parquet en extérieur sur plus de 95 %
de sa surface donc la météo est un
facteur essentiel jure une journée wild
bleus une journée me fait très beau on
va à peu près multiplier la
fréquentation par 4 ou par cinq la météo
un impondérable pour les parcs mais pas
seulement ces structures sont soumises a
plus d'aléa qu'on ne pourrait l'imaginer
notamment à cause de la clientèle on
essaie aussi nous de faire démarrer la
saison de plus en plus tôt alors cette
année on a quand même eu des soucis avec
le plan vigipirate ce qui fait que les
écoles ne sont pas du tout venu en mars
avril alors que d'habitude avec des
ateliers et des promos on arrive à les
faire venir plus tôt donc là tout s'est
concentré avec les ponts mais le début
de la saison pour les individuels juin
les scolaires qui n'avait pas du tout
réservé avant d'encaisser précipiter un
petit peu et c'était plus courts cette
année les petits visiteurs une cible non
négligeable à france miniature ils sont
plus importants que la clientèle
étrangère qui ne représente que 5% des
visites à l'année les écoles elles
viennent beaucoup à france miniature
dans le cadre de la de la sortie de fin
d'année voilà donc on est très fréquenté
par les écoles de la mi-mai à la fin
juin là on attaque les grandes vacances
est un petit peu de centres de loisirs
mais la partie école c'est presque 12 %
de la fréquentation du parc sur l'année
mais très concentrées sur le mois de
juin essentiellement ci ont dix ans le
marché des parcs à thèmes est passé de 3
à 35 millions de visiteurs par an les
visites de groupes scolaires seniors et
comités d'entreprises diminuent au
profit des familles ou amis à l'espace
rambouillet 80% des recettes viennent de
la billetterie sixième site le plus
visité des yvelines
son chiffre d'affaires s'élève à 1
million d'euros une somme presque
équivalente à celle nécessaire à
l'entretien du parc
on a besoin aujourd'hui de le rajouter
un petit peu en fin d'année pour un
point d'équilibré
mais alors les dépenses c'est la main
d'oeuvre les équipes et puis toute une
partie aussi de
faut nourrir les animaux et puis des
dépenses classiques d'entretien
d'infrastructures sur le site quoi il ya
un investissement de l'eau nf pour
boucler le budget annuel
l'espace rambouillet des bourses 40000
euros chaque année pour compléter
l'alimentation de ses animaux sauvages
c'est moins que les 400 tonnes de
nourriture achetée chaque année à thoiry
pour ses pensionnaires du côté de france
miniature les charges d'exploitation
s'élèvent à 2 millions d'euros par an il
appartient au groupe grévin et compagnie
est également propriétaire du parc
astérix comme touahri le parquet privé
et ne peut compter sur aucune aide ni
subvention
les deux lieux sont dans le classement
des 15 sites français qui attire plus de
trois cent mille visiteurs par an la
solution pour rester attractif et
rentable se renouveler en permanence
cette année thouars innove en
accueillant ces dinosaures
animatroniques un investissement de 300
mille euros pour une durée de trois mois
ça pousse à la revisite aussi on sait
que dans un parc zoologique les
visiteurs viennent à peu près tous les
trois-quatre ans le fait d'avoir une
expo quelque chose de phares
d'événements tous les ans je pense que
cela donnera aussi envie de revenir
parce que les animaux c'est toujours
différent un parc animalier ça se
renouvelle donc si en plus on appuie sa
avec un évènement saisonnier je pense
que ça sera sympa
une problématique différente pour le
parc forestier de rambouillet son
objectif fidéliser une clientèle plus à
la recherche d'immersion dans la nature
que d'évènements temporaires
on peut dire aujourd'hui avec un recul
de 40 ans par rapport au parc animalier
et de 20 ans par rapport à l'espace
rambouillet il ya il ya une vraie place
qui était trouvé et ça correspond pas
dire un public qui recherchent une
expérience nature est un petit peu
apaisées un point important c'est que il
ya à peu près 40% de nos visiteurs qui
reviennent en fait france miniature
développe plus l'évolution de son offre
en proposant des innovations ludique et
en misant sur l'interactif en complément
de ces maquettes bilan à la fin de l'été
2015 si le public est au rendez vous
mais les directeurs de parcs sont
confiants ce qu'on constate ici à france
miniature et d'hommes dans de nombreux
parcs c'est que les français ont l'air
de 2 - se pénaliser sur leurs loisirs
et beaucoup de parcs y compris nous qui
ferons une année 2015 meilleure que
celle de 2014
pour l'instant la météo nous aide
beaucoup depuis quelques mois mais on
pense aussi qu'il ya un petit
desserrement du porte monnaie des
français sur les loisirs qui est
favorable à l'ensemble des parcs
d'attraction ou les eaux enfin les sites
de loisirs en général
avec ses 200 parcs de loisirs la france
se place au 5e rang mondial sur ce
secteur et les civils ne devrait pas
être en reste
un projet de parc d'attraction d'une
vingtaine de manèges est en discussion
il devrait voir le jour en 2020 sur la
zone commerciale d'orgeval
c'est à présent la fin de notre émission
merci de nous avoir suivis pour cette
dernière émission de la saison je tenais
à remercier toute la rédaction pour son
travail le pôle infographie ainsi que
l'équipe de mon talent et surtout romain
ruiz finissants qui l'émission ne serait
pas la même
un grand merci également aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils ont suivi toute
cette saison et à monsieur sinon il ne
me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter de
très belles vacances sur téléphiles 78